that I'm a feminist.
That's why today,
I'm hosting my very own
gangbang, to prove that
women are not objects.
Look, men, you are not
penetrating our vaginas.
We are engulfing
your penises.
Think about it.
I want to thank the good
people at Sea Spray
for providing all
the cranberry juice
I'll be drinking throughout
the day.
I'm just really
proud to be here today,
like so many women who
have come before me.
Sandra Day...
Sotomayor, you know, tons,
too many to list.
Am I a hero?
Yeah, yeah,
I'm probably a hero.
Do I think today will
be a ton of fun?
I'm counting on it.
All right.
Let's just
get this started.
This is a couch
from home.
They're very cool about bringing
your own stuff into this space.
I can do this by myself,
I don't need a man to help
me with this.
You think famous
women from history,
you think Amelia Earhart,
says, oh hold on,
I parked the plane,
now I need help getting
this couch out.
Usually my roommate helps me
when I pull this out, but--
She had a test.
And she wasn't totally
into me doing this.
Okay, history in the making.
This is good,
this is comfortable,
this is gonna be fine.
Okay.
All right, gentlemen,
come on in.
( bell ringing )
Let's see who responded
to the Craigslist ad.
Okay, okay.
Not what I was picturing,
but okay.
There's more
of you, just like--
More keeps coming in.
You know what?
This is--
You look tired,
you look tired.
I'm tired.
It's too hot in here,
you know?
I'm feeling like maybe
I could just--
You know,
I mean, I still hate--
I hate that women are
objectified, I hate that,
but I'm feeling like I could
do a little less--
a little less to
prove that point.
I think-- You guys get that
women are equal to men, right?
You get that, right?
I don't know,
I guess.
Okay, then what
are we doing here?
The gangbang is
officially canceled.
Goodbye.
Thank you.
So there's no
gangbang today?
No, no.
I'm so sorry,
I'm sorry.
No, it's--
It's fine,
it's cool.
Wait, okay, excuse me,
I'm sorry.
What do you mean,
"It's cool"?
Well, I mean, I can't speak
for everybody,
but I mean,
as far as body types go,
I'm more into that girl
Whitney from that show
"Whitney,"
you know, no offense.
No, no offense.
Thanks for being honest.
You're cute,
but you're not Whitney.
So you're saying that
if--if I had stayed there,
you wouldn't have wanted
to do it?
No, I mean, I would have
done it, but, like,
my heart wouldn't
have been that into it.
Have a good afternoon,
ma'am.
"Ma'am"?
Wait, hold on, hold
on a second.
Everybody
just chill out, okay?
That was a test.
Gangbang is rescheduled
to right now.
We are still doing it.
It's back on.
Gangbang on.
Everybody,
come fuck me.
Fuck me, fuck me,
fuck me,
fuck me, fuck me.
Uh, slow down.
We're not pieces of meat.
Don't you find it to
be a little un-feminist
that you only want to
have sex with me
because I'm
not that into it?
Sounds like you want to be
objectified, don't you think?
♪♪